la tente l'angoisse à aisselles n'a pas
fermé l'oeil depuis deux jours un
puissante elle est incapable de
détourner le regard de Lama de ruines
devant elle ces trois neveux ils sont
coincés
nos enfants sont à l'intérieur nous
vibrent dit-elle on a appelé les secours
ils ne sont pas venus ils n'ont envoyés
aucune aide malgré leurs promesses
maintenant qu'ils y sont les secours
riches doivent avancer avec patience et
prudence malgré la machinerie lourde qui
ne manque pas de faire frémir les
familles qui attendent repérez les corps
dans les décombres c'est une chose mais
encore faut-il pouvoir les atteindre et
c'est là qu'on peut y mettre des heures
et des arts ici les secouristes ont
repéré deux personnes mais cherchent à
se frayer un chemin sans que tout ne
s'affaisse le Mokhtar le maire du
quartier tente d'apaiser le désarroi des
familles mais sa ville haussmannienne a
peu de moyens dit-il l'aide commence à
peine arrivé de l'extérieur
nous avons de l'espoir dit le maire il y
a six sept personnes toujours ensevelie
on a déjà retiré une personne pour les
autres on attend si Dieu le veut il
sortiront c'est notre prière
c'est une prière qui est répétée
au-dessus de milliers d'édifices en
ruine dans le sud-est de la Turquie et
en Syrie
ou à gazian tiep
mais souvent trop souvent elle ne l'est
pas comme ici à gendarys en Syrie voilà
il n'y a pas l'état pas d'équipement
pour aider les gens il n'y a pas
d'excavatrice ou d'équipement dur tout
est fait par nos mains des familles
entières sont encore coincées sous les
bâtiments 17 hommes venus avec l'espoir
de les sauver à cet extrait urgence de
déterrer les survivants s'ajoutent
celles de protéger jusqu'à 23 millions
de personnes qui se retrouvent
potentiellement exposées selon
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
environ 5 millions d'entre elles sont
vulnérables
c'est le cas de la famille Yuksek mais
il n'y pense pas encore pour l'instant
se leur père les préoccupent
ils n'ont commencé qu'à midi à
travailler ils ont retrouvé un mort on
attend encore dit-il résigner
son téléphone était fermé depuis des
heures et vers midi il s'est réactivé ça
fait 36 heures on pense qu'il y a encore
des vivants nous dit son frère
pour un instant la pelle mécanique
s'interrompsistes sa soeur retient son
souffle
lui ne voit pas bien et elle n'en peut
plus pour un instant elle sait ou
désespoir
mais les travaux vont reprendre sans
preuve du pire l'espoir n'est pas encore
complètement éteint ici Marie-Ève Bédard
Radio-Canada Haussmann